assorti de quelques temps un nouveau
smartphone c'est le zen phone 6 g pas si
vous avez suivi la dernière que j'ai
parlé du iphone 5 iphone 5 z
et puis d'autres smartphones de chez
asus et l'ajustement parle du zaï feu de
savoir le syphon 6 il a plein de belles
qualités de ceux qui sont vraiment bien
et des innovations des bell innovation
continue en avant par asus cette année
il ya des choix stratégiques qui sont
vraiment intéressants et qui se démarque
de la concurrence donc ça c'est vraiment
intéressant ce fameux iphone 6 on va en
parler ce iphone 6 on va en faire un
tour complet en partant de la lettre de
notification à l'avant jusqu'à l'arrière
de tous les côtés comtois pour dire que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
le zen fotsis et partie de cette
génération de produits qui est là pour
répondre à une problématique
particulière le fait d'avoir un grand
écran cent ans coche en profitant d'une
immersion réel au niveau d'un visionnage
de vidéos l'idée c'est effectivement de
mettre en avant le côté loisirs le côté
multimédia sur un très grand écran mais
en ne reniant pas sur la partie qualité
photo justement a vu ses compositions
très intéressant faut savoir qu'à
l'avant vous avez un écran de 6 4 pouces
d'une dalle épaisse et du lcd ici pas de
wade pour des questions de coupes
budgétaires résolution 2340 par 1080
pixels un écran que je trouve en tout
cas moi assez lumineux qui marche bien
grâce aux 19 points 5/9 pas du corning
gorilla glass 6 à l'avant smartphones
qui de notre cas pour être résistantes
on a aussi nos travail qui a été fait au
niveau du filtre de lumière bleue donc
ça c'est bien et vous avez un écran qui
occupent 92% de la face avant pour
trouver votre haut parleurs ici sur le
titre c'est plutôt cool ça marche bien
donc c'est vrai qu'on a une face avant
qui en tout cas remplit parfaitement sa
mission je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous le
savez vous apprendrez pas grand chose
les marques cherchent à vraiment libéré
leur face avant certains font avec des
petites caméras au peuple avec des
ailerons de requin est là le parti pris
par asus tel fait de se dire on va avec
la caméra arrière et elle va servir
également de caméras de celle fille
l'idée je trouve judicieuse bonne
intelligente et en plus ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est le fait de se
dire et bien à ce moment là le module
photo principale que je vais avoir un
arrière va aussi être bon au milieu
celle fils qui fait que vous avez
exactement la même qualité pour vos sept
filles et ça me semble vraiment très
intéressant par contre on peut se poser
la question de l'évolution de l'avenir
si asus tresse sur ce cette stratégie en
tout cas ils vont être limités s'ils
veulent augmenter le nombre de capteurs
ou alors il va falloir trouver une
solution différente face à k1ck peu plus
gros peu plus compliqué par contre comme
ça ça marche parfaitement bien vous avez
donc un double module photo avec une
caméra principale c'est la sound yannick
586 qui est une caméra de 48 mégapixels
elle va vous sortir des photos de 12
mégapixels complètement optimisé parce
qu' on va utiliser quatre pixels on va
regrouper en main ça me fera un seul
même gros pixels pour pouvoir capter
plus de lumière tu te caméra qui ouvre à
f 1.79 quelle auto focus laser enfin
fera un point dans quelques secondes là
dessus c'est plutôt bien et on a une
deuxième caméra son côté c'est un grand
angle très grand temps de 13 mégapixels
à 125 degrés
avec une correction de la distorsion
maintenant que j'ai un petit peu moins
c'est que trouve que le module photo
perdu en solo mais comme ceux de profils
ressort quand même pas mal ce qui fait
que lorsque vous peser sur une terre
comme ça il va avoir tendance un petit
peu à bouger et ça à cause du module
photo et c'est vrai que ça ce trouve ça
terrible et en plus la crainte que j'ai
c'est qu'à force à l'oreille du conte
est carrément dessus ça c'est vraiment
le truc qui me fait peur effectivement
c'est qu'on se dise voilà sa force de
frotter sa fille n'a pas effrayé
s'endommager est la fin d un appareil
photo complètement rayé donc des photos
floues je vous conseille donc de venir
protéger et pour ce faire vous avez et
les coques rhinos lorna partenariat
créneau chine vous le savez c'est
partout tout nouveau mais il faut des
produits qui sont vraiment très sympa et
qui justement venir protéger votre
smartphone et ça c'est cool
regardez cette jolie petite coche je
vais donc prendre sa tac tac tac tac tac
tac tac je mets ma coque et la chaussure
qu'à aucun moment ça va venir frotter ça
vous ne protège à l'avant comme à
l'arrière
vous avez toujours axé votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'arrière ça
c'est plutôt bien
au moins c'est une solution qui
intéressant alors vous avez celle
coquelin d'ailleurs j'ai un code de
promo de 10% chirino shit ça vous
intéresse le crash garde qui va venir
également le protège et qui me semble
est en tout cas une bonne alternative
vous venez vous le mettez autour de
votre smartphone enfin bien protégé ce
qui fait lorsque vous allez poser à plat
et bien ça va pas venir frotter et ça ça
me paraît quand même plutôt pas mal le
design ghislaine est plutôt bien réussi
avec vous avez sur le côté ici un bouton
qui est complètement personnalisable
vous pouvez utiliser pour rappeler
google assistant ne vous pouvez signer
dans vos réglages et choisir l'action
vous voulez que ce bouton ça c'est
plutôt intéressant le bouton de volume
le bouton on/off qu'un léger l'isad
bleus son côté est très élégant sol de
souvenirs trouvé ici un haut parleur de
la recharge en usb c'est une triste
diack très bon point que asus nous les
laisser là dessus son côté ici vous avez
à votre tiroir de 4,6 à savoir vous avez
la possibilité de mettre deux nanosims
plus une carte micro sd qui va jusqu'à
deux terrasses ça c'est vachement bien
au dessus votre petite caméra flip votre
micro par induction bruit au dos votre
caméra bien évidemment qui est
positionné ici et ici
le capteur d'empreintes digitales ça
c'est rustique un peu parce que du nil
et petit ne sait pas bien grave mais
c'est surtout que sa s'attend vraiment à
disparaître on retrouve encore surtout
sur les produits d'entrée et milieu de
gamme et là sur un produit comme ça
qu'on arrive plus dans l'idée du le
flagship qui leur trouve que c'est
dommage qu asus l'a mis là j'aurais
trouvé ça intéressant qui nous est un
capteur d'empreintes digitales optique
sous l'écran serait très bien marcher ça
aurait permis en tout cas asus d'être au
niveau d'autres marques et ce avec sur
un smartphone comme celui là c'est un
peu un point de rennes
peut-être ça ils marchent
merveilleusement bien et les verrouille
extrêmement rapidement mais ça va quand
on voit qu'on a un smartphone qui est
bien léché comme ça d'un point de vue
design qui est bien pensé bien travaillé
pour offrir un grand confort visuel avec
cette caméra flip là ça aurait été bien
que asus nous enlève ça je trouve que ça
aurait permis d'aller plus loin en tout
cas d'aller au bout au bout de l'idée
peut-être l'année prochaine sur un
iphone 7 pour voir que l'on naît une
belle évolution la joue c'est un petit
peu un point de regret c'est pas
extrêmement grave
mais bon côté performances c'est
vraiment un smartphone qui marche
extrêmement bien on à ce qui se fait de
mieux en terme de puissance aujourd'hui
qualcomm snapdragon 855 ce à l'heure
actuelle ce qui se fait de mieux ça
marche parfaitement bien c'est éprouver
soit 6 soit 8 gigas de ram première
gagner en fluidité déjà si jj abrams a
parfaitement bien à vous poser
absolument aucune question là dessus et
vous avez trois conflits qu en termes de
stockage c'est du f 2.0 ça marche aussi
assez rapide 64 giga de stockage 128 ou
alors carrément 250 gigas et je vous le
dis ce qui étouffe
c'est que lorsque vous allez mettre une
carte micro sd vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à 2 terrasses qui est quand même
énorme pouvoir mettre de la donner des
photos et tout ce que vous voulez là
dedans donc ça c'est plutôt bien aussi
mais si vous voulez sur optimiser votre
machine vous venez ici dans vos
paramètres vous avez la fonction booster
l'ia qui vous permettre de venir
apporter encore plus d'intelligence plus
d'optimisation attention c'est un peu
plus énergivores mais ça marche
parfaitement bien l'autonomie excellente
aussi avec une énorme batterie de 5000
millan paire eur avec ça vous avez temps
de voir venir vous pouvez le garder deux
jours sans souci si vous êtes un petit
peu plus titillé en étant le mode boost
il ya vous serez à un jour et demi mais
dans l'absolu ça très très bien en plus
avec la recharge compatible coude sharks
4 ducale comme ça c'est bien par contre
ici pas de recharge sans fil ce qui dans
l'absolu pour moi pour un très grave ça
ne pose particulièrement problème moi
qui s écoule par contre c'est le show
vous avez deux haut parleurs en haut
parleurs l'arrêt un deuxième haut
parleurs qui est ici c'est un petit peu
moins fort mais c'est vrai que ça nous
apporte quand même en sensation
d'immersion
là vous avez quand même mis un
haut-parleur qui envoie très très fort
hop j'ai coupé qui on va très très fort
qu'on m'a beaucoup de sons celui-là
légèrement moins mais c'est vrai qu'il
vient petit peu en renfort ça vous
apporte pas vraiment la sensation de son
stéréo 2 par le déséquilibre de
puissance mais c'est vrai qu'on a ce
petit enfant là et ça vient petit peut
apporter un peu de son essai plutôt pas
mal à côté de ça dans vos réglages vous
allez dans assistant audio et la faisait
pouvoir venir choisir le
que vous voulez lorsque vous l'écoutez
comme ça via les haut-parleurs ça va ça
marche bien vous avez quand même
suffisamment de puissance lorsque vous
allez écouter au casque choisissait
devient votre mode vous plantez pas
parce que si vous plantez que même un
truc un peu trop agressif que vous êtes
à plein volume
vous allez voir vous avez quand même pas
mal de puissance c'est plutôt bien mais
c'est vrai que ce qui est intéressant
avec cet effet d'abord steak wiseur avec
des modes qui sont déjà pré définis ou
alors carrément un mode manuel vous
faites ce que vous voulez vous
choisissez c'est bien parce que ça vous
permet quand même de profiter je dirais
d'une meilleure qualité audio on a cette
fois nos habitudes et en fonction de la
musique que vous à l'écouté vous allez
pas avoir la même règle soit vraiment
intéressant qu'asus et pensent à nous
mettre ce mode là haut niveau de l'audio
ça plutôt cool aussi et 12 sur l'a6
belle évolution très intéressant tout ça
basé sur un android 9 paille sous une
interface cas c'est correct y mange bien
vous avez bien évidemment du nfc du
bluetooth 5.0 mais surtout il ya un truc
que je voulais vous montrer que vous
êtes pas encore montré mais surtout il
ya un truc que je vais vous montrer que
vous êtes pas encore montré c'est la
qualité photo laurie sur le capteur
principal aston yannick 586 leur envie
je trouve vraiment bien très juste les
couleurs sont sympas il ya un bel
équilibre une belle plage dynamique
belle maîtrise du point de vue cet
appareil on arrive en tête sur la photo
prise avec la caméra grand angle
je trouve ça un peu moins bien un peu
moins cali le point ne paraît pas bien
fait sur la fleur qui est pourtant bien
au centre et il est bien pointé ça me
paraît être effectivement sinon dans
l'absolu pas trop mal pour que ça
marchera mieux peut-être pour des
paysages ou pour des groupes de
personnes criant photos sont prises
également que le capteur principal de 48
mégapixels c'est sympa ça marche bien
c'est très joli
le grand-angle on n'a pas tous la même
colorimétrie d'une image à l'autre
regardez le niveau des feuilles là on
tire un peu plus sur le jaune s'est pas
exactement ex de sousse a quand même
beaucoup moins efficace
après on passe ce sont deux caméras
différentes donc ça me paraît pas non
plus complètement dingue c'est assez
logique de ce point de vue là puisqu'il
photo sympathique le grand-angle
également caméra principale caméra à
grand angle
il faut dire que sont la caméra
principale vous avez un focus laser là
vous n'avez pas tout de suite le point
est beaucoup moins précis caméra
principale grand-angle c'est moins sympa
mais malgré tout ça fait le job
non mais sur une photo prise dans les
conditions nuit sur l'appareil photo
principale est bien trop missions de
nuit si je mets pas le mode nuit c'est
pas terrible terrible par contre dès que
je mets le mode nuit là c'est très
impressionnant le travail vraiment
intéressant et c'est là où on va tout le
travail de fait pas recette sony mx 5
186 4 pixels on n'y a vraiment pas de
lumière dans le studio voyez photo
normale
là par contre exposition est très longue
mais même si je viens ou un peu dedans
vraiment les traits le détail le visage
pour moi c'est vraiment cool et je fais
le même travail qu'un photo grand angle
il ya beaucoup de bruit on voit rien
donc de ce point de vue là sa marche
absolument pas je me porte quant à lui
ne marche pas trop mal là j'ai pas mis
trop de fou mais par contre quand je
mets beaucoup plus de flou ça des tours
plutôt pas mal
plutôt bien alors là j'ai vraiment
poussé à l'extrême donc et les petites
erreurs ici sur le côté mais bon j'ai
vraiment vraiment boosté booster truc
par contre détourage voyais au niveau
des cheveux se fait plutôt bien et c'est
au niveau des doigts par endroits qu'il
va avoir un petit peu de mal mais c'est
vraiment du point de détail sinon ça
marche quand même plutôt pas mal
il ya un mode qui va mal et qui est
assez malin scène mode suivi le
mouvement là il reconnaît mattel doit y
est il est en train de me suivre avec la
caméra je peux me décaler un peu sur le
côté
voyez la caméra sourd et là il est en
train de suivre donc ça c'est vraiment
l'ouverture la caméra elle s'ouvrait
l'encontre se décale et donc je trouve
que ça s'est assez malin c'est bien fait
c'est vraiment intelligent et le fait de
pouvoir utiliser justement le côté de
motoriser cette caméra très bon point la
part d'asus
mais le quotidien cette fonction
tracking n'avait pas particulièrement
l'utiliser ce qui est vraiment
intéressant est ce qu'on voit c'est à
juste cherche vraiment à profiter
pleinement de cette caméra et devant on
a une caméra qui est motorisé on va
pouvoir lui faire faire plein de choses
là justement tient qu'on peut lui faire
faire ça allait on attaque on peut faire
ça tiens on intègre donc ça c'est bien
et ça peut créer des usages pas
forcément pour monsieur et madame tout
le monde
mais imaginons par exemple voulez vous
filmez faire des vidéos youtube du blog
ou ce que vous voulez à négoce marche
folle et bien vous pouvez le faire avec
la fonction tracking vous pouvez vous
déplacer vous êtes tranquille vous avez
quand même une grande zone pour pouvoir
vous déplacez parfaitement
tranquillement et sachant ça plutôt cool
mais les bonnes idées ne s'arrête pas là
puisque en appuyant là vous pouvez venir
regarder lever votre caméra voulu régler
comme vous voulez elle vient se levait
up l'attelage pour qu'elle revienne
droite mais voyez ça c'est vachement
cool parce qu'au final vous pouvez venir
la règle et comme vous souhaitez hop on
l'a redescend voyez là hop paf ça bouge
et ça ça vraiment intéressant donc ça
c'est pareil c'est une intégration qui
est assez maligne à dire on peut le
faire on va le faire on va le proposer
permettra peut-être de faire un des
petits et travelling les films en ciel à
un avion qui passe ou je ne sais quoi
donc dans l'idée c'est un vrai sens
après on peut se dire attention il se
peut que votre caméra derrière elles se
referment mal et si toutefois c'est le
cas et bien sachez que vous avez une
possibilité qui est ici c'est la
fonction réinitialiser votre caméra vous
appuyer là-dessus au moins cela remet en
place à la fin bien vous êtes
tranquilles autres intégration qui est
plutôt intelligente c'est le mode
panorama il va se faire tout seul alors
d'habitude il faut venir bouger son
smartphone là ça fait tout seul vous
appuyer regardez le panorama ce fait la
caméra sort tout seul
hop tac tac tac tac tac alors voyez
quand il faut bien respecter
l'emplacement de la caméra mais voilà ça
bouffe et voilà ça vous avez votre
panorama et vous avez votre photo qui
est juste là à leur bon pour moi ne
servira pas à grand chose
mais imaginez que vous le faites sur un
extérieur voulait photographier un
paysage hop vous la mettez par contre
comme ça bien respecté l'axé une fois
vous l'avez fait donner des résultats
qui sont assez sympa et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est l'idée en tout cas eu
asus de se dire eh bien voilà on a une
caméra on va le faire comme ça bon
maintenant qu'elle est comme ça qu'est
ce qu'on en fait elle s'arrête juste à
le dégager l'écran on va pouvoir créer
des fonctionnalités et ils s'imbriquent
différentes fonctionnalités et cela
plutôt dans le bon sens en termes
d'expérience utilisateur donc ça ne
serait ce que pour avoir cette démarche
ces gros pouce bleus je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant comment on peut
retrouver beaucoup aujourd'hui vous avez
un accéléromètre qui va venir
complètement à bout sécurisé lorsque
vous allez me refaire des photos je lui
comme ça notre selphy hop je fais tomber
l'accéléromètre reconnaît la chique et
moi sur ma caméra immédiatement donc ça
c'est un truc qu'on retrouve aussi à la
concurrence sur les caméras et ros roca
ou pop-up
mais c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir un
côté rassurant pour le consommateur en
tout cas sachez que si votre smartphone
vous l'échappée et bien votre caméra
elle doit pas venir s'éclater comme ça
on a donc un smartphone qui est bien qui
va dans le bon sens
un grand écran dégager même si les
bordures sont un petit peu grande
c'est un peu dommage le fait de ne pas
avoir de howlett d'avoir du lcd
à ce tarif là ça peut paraître aussi un
petit peu dommage ce que je trouvais
aussi dommage c'est le fait d'avoir
capteur d'empreintes digitales à
l'arrière à côté de ça l'intégration de
la caméra est bonne les idées sont là le
produit est sympa une grosse autonomie
et de la performance
il ya un beau travail cat a fait de la
part d'asus sur ce smartphone et je
pense qu'il va séduire c'est pas déjà le
cas
beaucoup de mort alors qu'est ce qu'il
en est au niveau des tarifs tout se
passe ici à trois versions 64 giga de
stockage si giga de ram à 499 euros 99 6
jega drame s'en méfier de stockage à 559
99 et 8 gigas de ram prend le max de
fluidité 256 giga de stockage à 599,99
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
iphone 6 intéressant oui non qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette caméra qui
déplace le fus pouvoir faire ses
travellings est ce que vous voyez des
usages tout ça vous donne des idées
est ce que vous trouvez ça intéressant
de 8 à marquer tout ça en bas en
commentaire et puis comment vous la
trouvez par rapport aux autres solutions
qui sont apparus cette année le fait de
se dire qu'on est une caméra pop up
notamment sur le home and plus cette pro
le fait qu'on a mené le rond de requins
avec la caméra
frapper son côté comme ça avec le haut
pour et nos efforts et nos une fois dit
marc coma tous à hambach commentaires
dites moi ce que vous en pensez
je navigue bien évidemment à vous
abonner à rester connectés parce qu'on
va parler toujours plus d'actu de
smartphones il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui arrivent
à la rentrée une très grosse surprise
pas mal de chose n'allait pas ça va être
trop cool vous embrasse à demain ciao